nous savons que l'exposition à certains
agents peut augmenter le risque d'autisme.
En particulier, il y a un médicament, l'acide valproïque,
que les mères épileptiques prennent parfois,
et qui peut augmenter le risque d'autisme.
De plus, il peut y avoir des agents infectieux
qui sont également des causes d'autisme.
L'une des choses sur lesquelles
je vais me concentrer plus longuement
est l'étude des gènes qui peuvent provoquer l'autisme.
Je me concentre là-dessus non pas parce que
les gènes sont la seule cause d'autisme,
mais c'est l'une des causes
que nous pouvons aisément définir
et nous pouvons mieux comprendre la biologie
et mieux comprendre comment le cerveau fonctionne
de manière à mettre en place
des stratégies pour pouvoir intervenir.
Un des facteurs génétiques que nous ne comprenons pas,
est la différence que nous observons
entre les hommes et les femmes.
Les hommes sont quatre fois plus atteints d'autisme
que les femmes
et nous ne comprenons vraiment pas quelle en est la cause.
Une des façons de comprendre
que la génétique est un facteur
est de regarder ce qu'on appelle le taux de concordance.
En d'autres termes, si un enfant est autiste,
quelle est la probabilité
qu'un autre enfant de cette famille soit aussi autiste ?
En particulier, on peut observer
trois types de frères et sœurs :
les vrais jumeaux,
des jumeaux qui partagent 100%
de leur patrimoine génétique
et qui ont partagé le même environnement intra-utérin,
face à de faux jumeaux,
qui partagent 50%
de leur patrimoine génétique face à des frères
et sœurs ordinaires,
frère-sœur, sœur-sœur,
qui partagent également 50% de leur patrimoine génétique
mais n'ont pas partagé le même environnement intra-utérin.
Lorsque l'on regarde ces taux de concordance,
une chose frappante
est que pour les vrais jumeaux
le taux de concordance est de 77%.
On remarque, cependant,
que ce n'est pas 100%.
Il n'y a pas que les gènes qui interviennent dans les risques d'autisme,
cependant ils comptent en grande partie,
parce que lorsqu'on observe de faux-jumeaux,
ce taux de concordance est seulement de 31%.
D'un autre côté, il y a une différence
entre les faux-jumeaux et les frères et sœurs ordinaires,
suggérant qu'il y a des expositions communes
à ces faux jumeaux
qui pourraient ne pas être partagées
par des frères et sœurs ordinaires.
Cela nous prouve que l'autisme
est partiellement génétique.
Mais à quel point ?
En le comparant à d'autres pathologies
qui nous sont familières,
comme le cancer, les maladies cardiaques, le diabète,
on constate que la génétique joue un rôle bien plus important dans l'autisme
que dans n'importe quelle autre de ces pathologies.
Mais ceci ne nous dit pas quels gènes sont en cause,
ni même si chez un enfant en particulier,
c'est un gène ou une combinaison de gènes qui est en cause.
Et en fait, chez certaines personnes autistes
la cause est génétique !
Ça veut dire que c'est un unique
et puissant gène déterminant
qui cause l'autisme.
Cependant, chez d'autres personnes,
c'est génétique signifie
que c'est une combinaison de gènes
couplée avec le processus de développement,
qui a finalement déterminé le risque d'autisme.
Nous ne savons pas chez une personne en particulier
laquelle de ces deux réponses est vraie
tant que nous ne creusons pas plus.
Alors la question devient :
comment peut-on commencer à identifier
quels gènes exactement sont en cause ?
Laissez-moi établir quelque chose qui pourrait ne pas être intuitif.
Certaines personnes
peuvent être autistes
pour une raison génétique
sans pour autant qu'il y ait de l'autisme dans la famille.
La raison est qu'il peut y avoir chez
certaines personnes des changements ou mutations génétiques
qui ne sont pas transmis par la mère
ni par le père
mais qui sont nouvelles.
Les mutations sont présentes
dans l'ovule ou le sperme
au moment de la conception
mais n'ont pas été transmises
de génération en génération dans la famille.
Nous pouvons utiliser cette stratégie
afin de connaître et identifier
les gènes à la cause de l'autisme chez ces personnes.
En fait, à la Fondation Simon,
nous avons pris 2 600 personnes
n'ayant pas d'historique d'autisme dans la famille,
et nous avons pris l'enfant, la mère et le père
et nous avons essayé de comprendre
quels étaient ces gènes
qui sont cause d'autisme dans ces cas-là.
Pour faire cela, nous avons dû examiner
toute cette information génétique
et déterminer quelles étaient les différences
entre la mère, le père et l'enfant.
En faisant cela, je m'excuse,
je vais utiliser une analogie dépassée
tirée d'encyclopédies plutôt que de Wikipédia,
mais je vais le faire dans le but de vous faire comprendre
que pendant que nous faisions cet inventaire, nous
devions être capables d'examiner
des quantités massives d'informations.
Notre génome est organisé
en un ensemble de 46 volumes.
Pendant le processus, nous devions
pouvoir considérer chacun de ces 46 volumes,
parce que dans certains cas d'autisme,
il y a un volume qui manque.
Nous devions être plus précis que cela, cependant,
et nous avons commencé à ouvrir ces livres,
et parfois, la modification génétique
était plus subtile.
Cela pouvait représenter un unique paragraphe manquant,
ou, encore plus subtil que cela,
une simple lettre
une parmi trois milliards
qui était manquante ou modifiée, et qui pourtant
avait des effets importants
sur la manière de fonctionner du cerveau
et le comportement.
En faisant cela au sein des familles,
nous avons fait un compte-rendu
pour environ 25% des personnes
et déterminé qu'il y avait un unique
et puissant facteur génétique
qui causait de l'autisme dans ces familles.
D'un autre côté, il y a encore 75%
que nous n'avons pas encore compris.
En faisant ceci, cependant,
nous avons été ramenés à la réalité,
parce que nous avons réalisé qu'il n'y a pas
un seul gène qui cause de l'autisme.
En fait, les estimations actuelles
sont qu'il y a entre 200 et 400 gènes différents
qui peuvent causer de l'autisme.
Ceci explique en partie
pourquoi nous observons un spectre si étendu
quand il s'agit des effets.
Bien qu'il y ait autant de gènes,
il y a un certain ordre dans tout cela.
Ce n'est pas simplement du hasard
200, 400 gènes différents
mais en fait ils vont ensemble.
Ils forment une voie.
Ils forment un réseau
qui commence à avoir un sens maintenant
dans le fonctionnement du cerveau.
Nous commençons à avoir une approche ascendante
dans laquelle nous identifions ces
gênes, ces protéines, ces molécules, nous comprenons
comment elles interagissent entre elles
pour faire fonctionner
ce neurone, comment ces neurones interagissent entre eux
des circuits et comment ces circuits
fonctionnent, contrôlent le
comportement. Comprendre ceci chez des personnes autistes
et chez des personnes ayant des fonctions cognitives normales.
Mais un diagnostic précoce est la clé pour nous.
Être capable de faire ce diagnostic
à une personne prédisposée
durant un court laps de temps
où nous avons la possibilité de transformer,
où nous pouvons avoir un impact
sur ce cerveau en développement est crucial.
Donc des gens tels qu'Ami Klin ont développé des méthodes
afin de pouvoir prendre des enfants, des bébés,
et pouvoir utiliser des bio marqueurs,
ici le regard et la capacité à suivre des yeux,
afin d'identifier tout enfant à risque.
L'enfant que vous pouvez voir en train
de regarder cette femme dans les yeux
pendant qu'elle chante « L'araignée Gipsy »,
ne va pas développer d'autisme.
Ce bébé va être lavé de tout soupçon d'autisme.
D'un autre côté, cet autre bébé
va développer de l'autisme.
Cet enfant, vous pouvez le voir,
ne regarde pas correctement dans les yeux.
Au lieu d'avoir des yeux concentrés
et d'avoir cette connexion sociale.
Il regarde la bouche. Il regarde le nez.
Il regarde dans une autre direction
mais, encore une fois, il n'établit pas de connexion sociale,
et la capacité à faire ceci à grande échelle,
cibler les enfants qui ont des risques d'autisme,
au travers de quelque chose de robuste et fiable
va nous être d'une grande aide dans le but
de pouvoir intervenir à un stage précoce
où nous pouvons avoir l'impact le plus important.
Comment allons-nous intervenir ?
Ce sera probablement une combinaison de facteurs.
D'une part, chez certaines personnes,
nous allons essayer des médicaments.
Et donc, identifier les gènes pour l'autisme
est important pour nous afin de
pouvoir identifier ceux qui réagiront,
aux médicaments, ce qui pourrait avoir de l'impact
et être certain que c'est vraiment ce
que nous devons faire pour l'autisme.
Mais cela ne va pas être la seule démarche. Au-delà
de simples médicaments, nous allons utiliser des stratégies éducatives.
Parmi les personnes autistes,
certaines fonctionnent un peu différemment.
Ils apprennent différemment.
Ils absorbent leur environnement autrement,
et nous devons être capables de les éduquer
de la manière qui leur soit le plus profitable. D'autre part,
il y a beaucoup d'autres personnes
dans cette pièce qui ont de supers idées
concernant la technologie que nous pouvons utiliser,
les machines que nous pouvons utiliser pour entraîner le cerveau
pour le rendre plus efficace et
de compenser pour les domaines
où il rencontre des problèmes,
des choses, même, comme les Google Glass.
Vous pourriez imaginer, par exemple,
Gabriel, avec sa gêne sociale,
pourrait porter des Google Glass
avec un écouteur dans l'oreille,
et avoir un coach qui pourrait l'aider,
l'aider à réfléchir à comment converser, trouver des
amorces de conversation,
être capable peut-être même un jour
d'inviter une fille à un rencard.
Toutes ces nouvelles technologies
nous offrent des opportunités formidables
afin d'être capables d'avoir un impact
sur les personnes autistes,
mais pour l'instant le chemin est encore long.
De ce que nous en savons,
il y a encore tellement de choses que nous ignorons,
et donc je vous invite tous
à réfléchir pour nous aider à
améliorer ce que nous faisons,
utiliser notre connaissance collective en communauté
afin de faire changer les choses,
et en particulier, pour
les personnes dont la famille est touchée par l'autisme,
je vous invite à rejoindre le réseau interactif de l'autisme
pour faire partie de la solution,
car cela va nécessiter la contribution de beaucoup d'entre nous
pour penser à ce qui est important,
ce qui fera une différence significative.
Lorsque nous pensons à une chose
qui est une solution potentielle, à quel
point cela peut-il fonctionner ?
Cela va-t-il vraiment faire une différence
dans nos vies, en tant que personnes, en tant que
famille touchée par l'autisme?
Nous allons avoir besoin de personnes de tous âges,
des jeunes et des âgées,
de toutes sortes dans le spectre
du trouble autistique afin
d'être sûrs que nous pouvons avoir un impact.
Je vous invite donc tous à rejoindre la mission
et à nous aider pour être capables de rendre les vies
des personnes autistes
vraiment meilleures et plus riches.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)